pop chips makes a sweet potato flavor
I'm having a great day hey guys I'm just
Tuesday on it's grace and it's time to
talk back to you let's start over on
Twitter here it is
Lolita smiles new person-to-person new
person from it don't know what a new
person comments on something of mine of
social media I praise the crap out of
them and welcome them to the it's grace
family where hugs feel just as burning
as you tea ice sleet the smiles more
like Lolita smiles like a bag of flowers
like this still holdin on you can do it
but on a cruise I ran into someone from
Takota nation we are everywhere that's
awesome
as is the man in the background he's got
his flops on cargo shorts and his wife
Lauren Polo probably purchased at
t.j.maxx and he is all about that
Buffett any like dough anyway you guys
look great I hope you became best
friends forever and you told each other
things that you regret saying rear cam
new person to person to person rear cam
more like rear cam check out that book
your book having grace Helbig say nice
skin commercial before all my YouTube
videos makes commercials ok don't you
like the fresh hydration lotion spray
it's light and airy and weighs less than
a fetus on your skin fans blue eyes new
person a person in person Dan's blue
eyes more like Dan's blue eyes with
makeup great I donno or someone that
doesn't have blue eyes but always wanted
blue eyes like me you're now going to
watch two weeks worth of grace Helbig
well I attempt to write a comparative
essay here's a comparative essay
versus conclusion now let's go to
tumbler Danny Henson new person to
person to person Danny Heinsohn more
like Danny hi nice
Jaime is a great word Heidi and weiner
are two of the most underappreciated
words in the English language boo boo
boo one month until no filter London
that's right there is one month until
memory and Hannah and I descend upon
London town to eat all of the fish into
chips and until and do the comedy we'll
see what happens
have you bought your tickets I believe
it's completely sold out so that was a
rhetorical question
awkward like brace new person new person
in person awkward like grace more like
half I oh my god please just hang on for
a little bit longer
my mother understands me so well I came
home to see this one wall your mom put a
quote that I said on your wall that is
so cool you have a cool mom and that is
very unfulfilled in her life and
therefore fills her time with craft red
X cows goal new person new person to
person red X cows call more like red
Excalibur
mmm knights of the round Shirley tablet
people this is literally my favorite
thing is that I feel you have other
things that are more special than this
now let's go to you to move touching
your butt 17 new person to person to
person 17 more like add a year and then
I'll pay attention to you lately
speaking you improve your effects are so
impressive when I was younger I wanted
to be in your magazine what a weird
moment this is for me I feel an urge to
shower a the scene new person to person
to person agency
d e f g what an interesting name you
have a bride she lives to troll and I'm
okay with it
because I live control the future
I love troll 2 then a what role inside
truth well there you go that's all for
talking back to you on this Tuesday I
hope that you enjoyed your time here
because I was here I don't know some of
you Lynch new person to person to person
so V Lynch more like Sophie's Choice she
chose a number 3 with french fries we
just found out I'm going to the Dublin
no filter show I cannot wait well you're
gonna have to wait a little bit
hopefully you'll figure out to take caps
locks off in the meantime though who am
I to judge
I love cat Fox